do you remember back in school when they
said that the stone blocks cut by the
ancient Egyptians were so precise that
you couldn't fit a razor blade or even a
human hair in between them
well this is what they meant look at
that the Precision cut of these massive
and extremely hard Granite blocks is so
unbelievably exact that it's difficult
to even differentiate the two stones
together the high definition camera
itself despite all its megapixels
struggles to pick up this line it's
something that can only be truly
appreciated when viewed in person with
the naked eye and if you think this is
impressive wait until you see the photos
from other parts of ancient Egypt that
I'm going to show you later in this
video but what you're seeing here are
the enormous polygonal stone blocks that
make up the valley Temple which is
located in front of the Great Sphinx in
Giza Egypt this is one of those sites
that most people are unaware of as the
Great Sphinx and the pyramids get all
the attention but it is without a doubt
one of the most spectacular sites found
from ancient Egypt many of these Rose
Granite blocks are well over 30 tons
apiece however the immense difficulty to
construct a temple made out of polygonal
shaped Granite pieced together as if a
tight-fitted puzzle is next level
difficulty made to last Millennia and
survive even the strongest of
earthquakes and when I said that these
stones are massive you have to compare
them to people to truly appreciate their
size and that's me there I'm 5 foot 10
or 178 centimeters even with this photo
you can't truly appreciate it as this
was shot with an ultra wide camera lens
which distorts the true size and the
bulk of these blocks particularly their
widths it does not do it justice for
what your eyes witness here in person
and and by the way this this particular
block is closer to 50 tons in weight and
brought from more than 500 miles away
which the experts theorize must have
been carried by boat down the Nile River
however the bizarre reality is that even
the largest known ancient Egyptian boat
ever found couldn't possibly sustain
even a fraction of the weight of these
Stones make no mistake the mystery is
real hence why there is a surging
interest by millions of people from
around the world into our lost ancient
past
but that aside and going back to the
unbelievable Precision that makes up
these Stones notice that from a distance
you can't possibly appreciate just how
tightly cut and formed together they are
you see many of these blocks are cut
with rounded edges thus creating a seam
or groove of sorts between the blocks
but when you get up close you can see
that in the middle of these seams is
they cut so perfect that they are
completely flushed together as if they
were laser cut in fact they almost look
fused together and you'll find awesome
examples all throughout this magnificent
structure take this example here from a
bit of a distance you wouldn't realize
just how exact the cut is again due to
the breath of the seams virtually all
the blocks that make up this astounding
Stone complex are like this it's simply
fascinating
from a distance you wouldn't think much
of the methods you used to cut these
stones but it's not until you get up
close that you can appreciate the level
of accuracy it truly is next level but
you should know that this is not some
one-off fluke example as there are
countless others found throughout the
land of ancient Egypt even the ground
itself has been lined with such
unbelievably precise stone blocks that
without careful inspection you might not
notice at all and like I just said Stone
cuts that are so fine that it's
difficult for even cameras to pick up on
just compare this line cut to a hotel
room key which is of course the size of
a credit card the exactness of these two
blocks that are pieced together makes
the width of that card look thick in
comparison
because again notice how you can hardly
see that line from even just a few feet
above it and you'll be curious to know
that this example here is only a few
steps away from the Great Pyramid of
Giza in fact it's right next to it you
see something that most people are not
aware of is that the entire ground
surrounding the pyramids are covered in
flooring stones and there are thousands
of them many of which are polygonal in
shape cut and pieced together perfectly
again as if a puzzle you see it becomes
even more interesting when you realize
that these stones have been there for at
least four thousand five hundred years
beneath the blaring sun and elements of
erosion including wind rain weather and
of course millions of humans that have
walked on stumbled and further
deteriorated these blocks in the
thousands of years since
and examples of polygonal flooring
Stones can be found at various temples
throughout Egypt even in the most
unlikely places such as the roof of the
Temple of hattor in dandera hundreds of
polygonal Stones which although
weathered and eroded upon a closer
inspection you can see just how precise
these Stone cuts are
but getting back to the even more
impressive stuff wait until you see this
the so-called bent Pyramid of Egypt is a
place that very very few people have
seen with their own eyes as it's been
closed to the public and even
archaeologists for several decades even
the most notable researchers have been
denied access to enter inside this
pyramid that is until it finally opened
in the summer of 2019 and I had the
great timing and privilege to me among
the very first tourists to enter this
utterly bizarre structure in December of
2020 and I filmed the entire thing and
if you're interested in seeing the
incredibly bizarre interior structure
and layout of this pyramid you'll want
to check out my video tour of it after
this video but when you enter inside and
Traverse the tunnels of cut Limestone
that makes up the structure you see
Precision Cuts the likes of which are
nothing short of astounding look at that
like I mentioned earlier many of these
cuts are so exact that it's difficult
for the camera to differentiate the
blocks together even notice this example
of three stone blocks joined ignore the
damage and imperfect exterior portions
of the stone block which naturally catch
your eye and focus on the line cuts
themselves whoever built this clearly
chose to make the fin leading of the
blocks to a level of perfection while
focusing Less on the exterior portion of
blocks that make up the pyramid tunnels
and you'll notice that this is the case
from floor to ceiling throughout this
pyramid and these blocks are by no means
small yet cut so perfectly that they
align so tightly that not even a razor
or human hair could fit in between them
I'd even venture to say that they're
probably water tight as well and do not
be fooled by their soft chalk-like
appearance you could push your
fingernail into this Stone as hard as
you possibly could and it won't even
scratch it as the saying goes they are
as hard as a rock and examples like this
where we see the intersection of three
stone blocks connecting at such a fine
degree of accuracy provides us with a
wonderful perspective that illustrates
just how remarkable the capabilities
were for the people that made this
but that's the thing and this is where
things start to get really weird so
before I show you more astonishing
photos there's something you need to
know and most people are completely
surprised at what I'm going to share
next because it shows just how truly
mysterious the ancient Egyptians are you
see these bronze chisels here and just
so you know bronze is a combination of
copper and Tin but you see these other
various bronze tools here as well
including small handheld saws and here
are a few more examples of various
Egyptian tooling all of which are on
display in the Cairo Museum in Egypt I
took these photos myself
all of these tools you're seeing are
literally the only examples of the types
of known tools utilized by the ancient
Egyptians that have ever been found just
to clarify these are not the only number
of chisels or saws ever found but they
are the only types of tooling ever found
to exist from the ancient Egyptians
that's right and here's something else
you need to know is that out of the
hundreds of thousands of hieroglyphics
found throughout the land of ancient
Egypt not one single one of them shows
anything about how the Egyptians cut or
carve stone or constructed the pyramids
literally zero whatsoever and that's a
verifiable fact by the way it's just
that most people are completely
surprised when they hear that for the
first time you see what happened is we
were sewn animations like these as
children in school not realizing that
this is nothing more than some theorized
drawing created only recently for school
textbooks a bunch of primitive dudes
wearing nothing but loin cloths using
soft bronze chisels to shape the stones
that make up the pyramids of Egypt but
here is the reality of what happened
when people actually tested these
primitive alleged methods in modern
times
after days of work their copper chisels
and stone Pounders are barely making a
dent
[Music]
Brown is wearing down tools at an
extraordinary rate
the copper chiseled the ancient
Egyptians would have used last only a
few dozen strikes
that was a notable egyptologist testing
Stone Hammers and bronze chisels on
limestone in an attempt to recreate the
Sphinx's nose and you heard what they
said after a few days of work and they
barely made a dent and the chisels
themselves after just a few dozen
strikes were worn out and useless
so clearly not a feasible explanation
and what you didn't see is that later in
this documentary they completely gave up
and resorted to using power saws to
finish the task
but that was bronze chisels on Limestone
wait until you see what happened when he
tried it on granite when Roger tries
chiseled made from bronze the results
are disappointing
as you can see we're just we're leaving
a lot of metal and very little stone is
flaking up
yeah so no obviously bronze chisels were
not the methods of tools utilized by the
Egyptians or anyone to Cotton carve
Stone of any kind
which is why it is so bizarre to see
that this is still a primary explanation
that is taught today they even have it
posted as descriptions within museums
and the reason for this is because the
people writing ancient history books in
modern times have concluded that these
must be the types of tools that were
used since they are the only types of
tools that have ever been found so Case
Closed mystery solved but they
proclaimed that without ever having
tested these primitive alleged methods
themselves and bronze chisels aside the
more commonly accepted explanation for
cutting the granite and Limestone blocks
involves copper saws but again these are
the only examples of saws ever found
from the ancient Egyptians and not only
that the only depictions of the
Egyptians using saws of any kind are
these right here which clearly shows
them using small saws to cut wood for
constructing Furniture so watch what
happens with that same egyptologist Mark
laner used a copper saw to demonstrate
how it could have been used to cut
Granite blocks
all right we have a big block of granite
here so how's this copper going to cut
this Granite even with teeth the copper
alone is too soft we're going to put
sand inside the groove and we're going
to put this saw on top of the sand and
then let the sand do the cutting
so Dennis will we see any progress in
our lifetime yes
um if you came back in an hour's time
you would see about a four millimeter
cup down into the film you're kidding in
an hour you'll be four millimeters down
well I've been doing a lot of
experiments and I can guarantee that
this will cook through the stone that's
about four millimeters an hour
[Applause]
sorry went wonderful once we switched
over to using uh water with the sand as
you can see here we achieved this in
just a few days
four millimeters an hour and just a few
inches over a few days are you kidding
me so besides the fact that no saw of
this size was ever found nor was there
any saw of this size ever found to be
depicted by the Egyptians but we can
clearly see that this method is so
unbelievably so or slow that it could
possibly be a feasible explanation for
how the Egyptians cut and carved the
millions of stones that make up the
pyramids because keep in mind that the
Great Pyramid of Giza is made of some
2.3 million stone blocks and was said to
be constructed over approximately 20
years that means that they would have
had to cut carve move in place at least
one stone block every few minutes to
achieve that timeline and this does not
include the many millions of more stone
blocks that make up more than a hundred
other known pyramids found throughout
Egypt many people are not aware of just
how many Egyptian Pyramids there are and
all of which were said to be done within
a very specific timeline for their
respective Pharaoh at least according to
the alleged story that we've been taught
in Modern Times And I wonder just how
many millions of blocks would make up
that 118 pyramids because of course
they're all of differing sizes and
dimensions
and this does not include the many
millions of stone blocks that make up
the dozens of various temples found
throughout Egypt this is just a few
examples all of which were made from
countless stacked blocks nor does it
include the countless flooring stones
that surround these temples and the
Pyramids of Giza itself nor does it
include the hundreds of various
structures including mustabas all of
which are made of stone blocks nor does
it include the countless stones that
make up the many columns found at dozens
of sites throughout Egypt nor does it
include the many gigantic Stone obelisks
giant Stone boxes as well as the
countless Stone sarcophagi found all
over the place far more they could
possibly be shared in this video and nor
does it include the thousands of
incredible stone statues that have been
found throughout the land of ancient
Egypt and it sure doesn't include all of
the other random incredibly shaped
Granite stones that were once part of
structures that are long since gone
impeccably curved Granite that couldn't
possibly be done with the known tooling
found in Egypt is at least as far as
what you've just seen and you don't have
to be a stone Mason archaeologist or
even a freaking rocking scientist to
comprehend that these tools here copper
Saws and chisels did not create the cuts
of this level of precision and this
certainly does not even address the size
of these stones and the time it would
take to do it which is of course a major
factor that must be considered but
there's even more proof that these
blocks were not cut with two guys
holding on to some handheld saw
this Granite sarcophagus is one of many
that are on display and the Cairo Museum
in Egypt however what makes this
particular Stone box so unique is that
it's listed as being discarded by the
Egyptians as on the other side you see
that they made a mistake in the cut and
it went off center
but this in itself is evidence that the
Egyptians were not using some
unbelievably slow primitive handheld saw
because if that was the case they would
have noticed and corrected their mistake
almost immediately the fact that it
continued off center for nearly another
three feet strongly indicates that they
were using a method that was Far quicker
and Superior the evidence is right in
front of us
like I always say look and think for
yourself there are far too many details
that weren't shown to us when we learned
about the Egyptians as kids but when you
revisit this amazing topic as an adult
with more life experience and the
ability to use discernment you can see
just how real the mystery is yet despite
all the details I shared in this video
many will still adamantly defend these
debunked narratives but you have to keep
in mind that many of these people that
propose these alleged methods have never
actually been to Egypt themselves and
nor have they physically tried to cut a
stone block with these primitive methods
either and those who have attempted it
have given up they've never finished one
single block they do it for a little bit
and realize like oh wow this is
extremely difficult and just stop right
there I mean isn't that interesting
because between all the stone cut blocks
that make up the hundreds of pyramids
temples various stone structures
flooring Stones columns obelisks statues
Stone boxes and sarcophagi and every
anything else I wouldn't be surprised if
the Egyptians cut at least 50 million
stone blocks maybe even closer to 100
million perhaps I mean who knows yet you
will not find one single example in
modern times of a fully cut stone block
that was done with these primitive
methods isn't that interesting you have
the Egyptians with tens of millions of
stone blocks maybe even 100 million I'm
just throwing out a number here but tens
of millions No Doubt
and yet we haven't done one in modern
times
it's clear that the ancient Egyptians
had some sort of lost technology and by
technology we shouldn't just think
computers and lasers and anything else
in our mind technology itself can be
something quite simple I mean even a
saddle on a horse is considered a
technology we have to think out the box
outside the box and it doesn't have to
involve aliens because that's usually
what people say when they argue against
these these methods say oh so let me
guess you think it was aliens right it's
like
what's that about like I'm not
suggesting aliens and very few people
that are discussing these methods have
said aliens it's just that you need to
look at this with open eyes and see that
the mystery is here when you see this
stuff as an adult you can see just how
real the mystery is but I'm going to
wrap it up here my next video will be
out very very soon
and if you want to see more amazing vote
uh pictures of these Stones go to my
Instagram I'll leave a link down in the
description and I'll leave it a link for
my Tick Tock I created an account I
haven't put a video up yet but I have to
now Branch out in order to bring more
people to this Channel and I I didn't
want to get on Tick Tock but now I
realize that that platform is just too
big and it's not going away so if you're
interested go down there because I'm
going to be making a whole bunch of
videos in a short period of time to
launch that thing but anyways I'll leave
it at that my name is Jimmy my channel
is called bright insight
take care everybody